als die esoterikerin da noch ihr pegel
rausholt um die aura des lagers zu
checken wird es auch bild zu viel ist
kann es sein das kann es einfach nicht
sein
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute schön dass ihr heute wieder
eingeschaltet habt ich habe die weiten
des internets für richtig fastet und
habe ein weiteres absolutes drecks video
gefunden dieses videos in bester von
daniela also der saane süchtigen frau
aus family stories bestand gleich sofort
ins video rein aber bevor wir loslegen
wollte ich noch eine sache sagen und
zwar liest sich sehr gerne im euro
kommentare und ich habe den letzten
wochen verwaist die kommentare gelesen
die leute gesagt haben das ist ihnen
tendenziell bisschen zu viel action
videos sind das nehme ich sehr ernst das
heute sagen es ist einfach gerade die
art von content die sehr viele zuschauer
mir gefällt und die mir auch sehr viel
spaß auch beim aufnehmen deswegen kommen
letzter zeit zu viel davon aber dass
leute die auch noch andere video
wünschen schreibt ihr abrunden gerne die
kommentare hier ist die durch und wie
gern auf ein
wie gesagt das ganze hier sind best auch
das heißt es gibt eine die legendärsten
und hochwertigsten szenen von unserer
lieben sahne süchtigen daniela zu sehen
ich bin sehr gespannt vergangen die
reporterin daniela pastoors drei mann
zählt große clownskostüm wie angegossen
acht sekunden alt und da jeder wurde er
schon so hardcore von ihrer eigenen
sendung geleistet ich meine die scheiße
ist das so wenn über die youtuber
darüber mitzumachen und sieben leute
lust machen okay aber es ist rtl 2 der
sender der ihr gehalt bezahlt roche
indem sie in der sendung sagen dass ein
drei mann zelt großes klaus kleid ihr
perfekt passt 428 mysteriöser clown
wahrgenommen werden möchte von allen
gerade auf jobsuche hat sich im radio
jobsuche selbstverständlich dafür
entschieden die hoch renommierte und
überaus professionelle
aus richtung des clowns zu wählen jeder
ferien war will als religiöser clown
wahrgenommen werden müsste wie man das
heute keiner deutschkurs auch simon
worten das ist so wie schwarzes schaf
seriöser clown diesem kindergeburtstag
weiß irgendwie zufällig ob da jemand ein
ableben plant oder was wir da hin wo es
eben anders wird eine grabkerze und
daniela bereitet sich professionell auf
ihren auftritt auf dem kindergeburtstag
vor sie will er als seriöser klauen
wahrgenommen werden und dann kauft die
als vorbereitung für einen
kindergeburtstag
eine grabkerze eine kerze die speziell
dafür entwickelt ist auch gräbern zu
stehen also über erdlöchern bedrohte
leute drin liegen jetzt ist dann wähler
nicht mehr zu bremsen
völlig überdreht landet die 120 kilo
frau in der liebevoll gestaltete
geburtstagstorte ja was soll ich sagen
leute an diese szene ist schon wieder so
viel einfach grundlegend falsch warum
muss man dabei betonen dass die brauchen
seit 20 kilo hätte er zwei ungemein da
fernsehsender jetzt kann eben schon
gesagt dass ein drei mann zählt ihr
gerade so um den körper passt ok muss
man jetzt aber betonen dass die 120 kilo
wiegt und dazu auch absolut legendär
vehicle schauspieler wird wie sie aus
versehen in den kuchen reinfeldt völlig
überdreht landet die 120 kilo frau in
der liebevoll gestaltete
geburtstagstorte das sieht nicht aus als
wenn sie aus versehen da eingefallen das
sieht aus wie ein riesling ruf
seriöser clown wahrgenommen werden aber
macht fucking wrestling moves gegen
kinder
[Musik]
daniela als seine königin geht natürlich
nicht ohne diverse sprühdosen aus dem
haus und kann jetzt hier einfach perfekt
ihren ellbogencheck gegen die kinder
geburtstagstorte wieder ausreichend mit
sahne oder auch nicht dieselbe
liebhaberin ist völlig in ihrem element
und verteilt großzügig sprühsahne auf
der geburtstagstorte
[Musik]
das ist einfach nur traurig wird auch
heute sag mir bitte was dieser sache
einsatz bei der torte gebracht haben
soll
was hat es gebracht nichts das ding
sieht noch beschissener auch das feuer
das toben mit den kindern macht hungrig
deshalb beschließt nimmersatt daniela
den kuchen auf ihre ganz eigene und
praktische weise zu verteilen die kinder
sind irritiert
[Musik]
ich glaube leute safety first
mysteriös
staffel
wisst ihr wie sich das anfühlt das ist
wirklich so an dem punkt von kranj
angelangt wo man einfach tatsächlich
innerliche schmerzen hat es ist längst
nicht mehr so dass man sich denken okay
das ist unangenehm das ist freilich nein
wenn man sowas sieht es ist wirklich so
ich könnte mir jetzt nicht ein fucking
samurai-schwert nehmen und es mit anlauf
in die magengrube hinein passieren dass
er ungefähr das gefühl feierte die kg
jetzt schon doppelt rein oder was ich
hatte doppelstrategie der alten tanten
dem komischen clown shop und eine frau
hat eine doppelte ration nervennahrung
was aber da fragt gesehen natürlich
effekte logik daniela hatte doppelten
stress als gesagt laut gelacht muss man
sich natürlich erstmal eine doppelte
ladung saale in den schlund mit
hochdruck hineinpressen ok verständlich
der kindergeburtstag stress wurde ihr
scheinbar zu viel deswegen hatte sich an
der stelle dafür entschieden den
stationen zu machen ihrer keine ahnung
wer das ist jetzt was passiert die
beiden machen spazieren laufen herum von
seen auf einmal den grauenhaften anblick
eines baumes mit schon so drei
reißzwecken drin also der baum ist quasi
aber rasch drei reißzwecken auch schon
40 meter baum ist ja klar der ist tot
prinzipiell sollte ganz gleis nicht wie
jetzt der 2
irgendwo sitzt indischen sauber stabs
geschäft aber noch lebt daniela hat
jetzt nach eingehender professioneller
untersuchung mit der afrikanischen
wünschelrute festgestellt dass der baum
krank ist aber ganz märz sollte mal kurz
ironie und sarkasmus beiseite wenn man
so sehr geistig am ende ist dass selbst
eine 13-jährige sich nicht mehr geben
kann was man selbst als 35 jährige sagt
dann weiß man es ist zeit für die klapse
da kannst du so nicht schreiben so dass
man gut zu dem brötchen war
du musst du den kunden gut sein warum
muss man gut zu brötchen sei nicht
normal so absurd leute scheinbar das auf
wundersame art und weise mit der
anstellung als seriöser klar nicht ganz
funktioniert deswegen ist denn jetzt
weiß ich auf eine stelle als bäckerin zu
bewerben
dazu immer gut zu dem brötchen war du
musst du den kunden gut sein und freunde
okay was ist dass leute sagt mir was was
schaue ich mir da gerade brötchen müssen
gut behandelt werden
ganz ehrlich ich habe so lange so meine
zweifel dass family stories oder
generell rtl2 überhaupt auf der erde
spielt welcher mensch auf der erde würde
auf die idee kommen so was zu sagen oder
sowas in skript reinzuschreiben findet
sender ich sag es offiziell leute und es
kann gut sein dass ich für diese
erkenntnis bald nicht mehr unter uns
weilen
diese rtl2 serien hilf mir gras schule
family stories werden von dreiköpfigen
aliens auf alpha centauri produziert
glaube jetzt sowas kann nicht von der
erde
das ist ja wohl beim ausdrucken habe ich
einfach dazu gut machst aufkleber drauf
das argument verstanden man noch
aufkleber auf eine bewerbung damit sie
auffällt sollte sich nach doppelarbeit
ich habe eine frage ich habe gehört die
suchen personal
ja das stimmt haben sie irgendwelche
unterlag dabei nicht mehr wahrgenommen
aber bzw
geschrieben und mitgebracht okay das
jetzt so ziemlich die erste szene vista
die halbwegs normal verläuft sind best
of einfach alle drei sekunden ein
kopfstoß moment vielleicht hat sich ihr
leben aber jetzt im griff bekommen und
den job in der bäckerei leute drücken
wir die daumen
sechs anfangen den laden aufmachen
ich meine die solchen dass wir das
schaffen werden bin ich total müde dann
wo ich brauche meinen schlaf und um die
tour zeitfahren auch noch keine
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel fahren war
erst kurz vor 6 bitte sagt mir dass wir
jetzt nicht das macht was ich denke holt
sie jetzt pendelt raus weil sie nicht um
6 uhr anfangen zu arbeiten und versucht
die bäckerei verkäuferin zu bekehren
es ist dass falls die esoterikerin da
noch ihr pendel rausholt um die aura des
ladens zu checken führt es auch dirk zu
viel
ist kann es sein das kann es einfach
nicht sein
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
das war sowieso wieder leute gepriesen
sei rtl 2 die krisen seien die drei
kräftigen aliens gepriesen sei daniela
für unseren täglichen fremdschaden hier
drüben habe ich euch ja zufällig video
vor dem check das gerne abholen wie
gesagt schreib mir auch wieder in die
kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal